aujourd'hui on se parle d'audio je vous
parle de ces écouteurs là ce sont les
Huawei les freebds pro 3 et c'est
vraiment une très jolie surprise c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui ralis en
collaboration commerciale avec Huawei
Huawei m' dit gre est-ce que tu veux
venir découvrir tester nos nouveaux
écouteurs et bien évidemment nous donner
ton retour je vous le dis très
honnêtement c'est une très jolie
surprise je connais depuis longtemps le
savoir-faire et la qualité des produits
Huawei je sais avec quel sérieux ils
viennent travailler avec toutes leurs
équipes d'ingénieurs sur les différents
produits qu' peuvent venir sortir et
c'est vrai qu'ici au niveau de l'audio
c'est super bon et je vais vous le dire
en plus il y a énormément de technologie
à venir détailler donc accrochez-vous on
y va et avant de commencer je vous dis
tout de suite il y a un code promo de 20
€ pour venir les acheter moins cher ce
sont des écouteurs à la base qui coûtent
199,99 € et qui grâce à ces 20 € de
moins vous aurez à
179,99 € c'est donc le bon moment pour
venir les acheter profitez-en pour venir
acheter ces Huawei freebuds Pro 3 côté
design on retrouve un petit galet super
efficace très joli qui tient bien normal
donc ça c'est quand même vachement cool
moi la couleur que j'ai ici c'est le
vert mais il existe également en blanc
céramique ou en argent lorsque vous les
ouvrezintérieur vous trouvez vos
écouteurs que je trouve une fois de plus
très joli très élégant avec un embout en
silicone au niveau du confort il y a
aussi qu chose qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que Huawei est venu
alléger légèrement ses buds on est ici 5
% plus léger pour des écouteurs qui font
5,8 g pièces et ce qui est très malin
c'est qu'ici vous avez la taille M qui
est installée par défaut mais il en
existe plein d'autres vous avez du XS du
S du L comme ça ça pourra convenir à
toutes les oreilles donc ça une fois de
plus c'est quand même vachement bien
pensé si c'est un truc qui m'a
extrêmement bluffé ici c'est vraiment la
qualité audio qu'on vient retrouver avec
une fois de plus c'est Huawei freebuls
Pro 3 pourquoi et bien parce qu'il y a
énormément de techno que Huawei est venu
mettre à l'intérieur et on sent qu'il y
a vraiment une très grosse maîtrise ici
au niveau de l'ingénierie audio ça
marche vraiment bien Huawei nous annonce
qu'on peut descendre jusqu'à 14 Hz 14 Hz
ce sont pas des fréquences que vous
allez vous pouvoir entendre à votre
oreille mais on va pouvoir venir les
ressentir on descend jusqu'à 14 Hz et on
monte jusqu'à de la même manière 48 kHz
une fois de plus le 48 kHz vous n'allez
pas venir venir l'entendre c'est pas
percepti par vos oreilles mais ce que je
ressens réellement c'est que je vais
avoir une bande de fréquence extrêmement
large lorsque je viis écouter différents
morceaux je sens que j'ai une rondeur au
niveau des basses ça descend c'est grave
c'est beau et j'ai vraiment une finesse
aussi au niveau des aigus je le retrouve
notamment sur des sballes j'ai vraiment
cette clarté on sent ici que toute la
bande de fréquence est extrêmement bien
utilisée et sans prédominance que ce
soit de médium d'aigu de grave et de
bande de fréquence qui serait un peu
bizarre tout se pass ici dans votre
appli ation qui s'appelle High Life dans
laquelle vous allez venir retrouver vos
différents objets connectés de Huawei et
ici vos freebuds Pro 3 une fois de plus
Huawei fait pas les choses à moitié ils
ont voulu aller encore plus loin en
travaillant avec leurs équipes d'inget
derrière on se disant ok c'est bon on a
une très belle qualité sonore mais on n
pas tous le même conduit auditif on va
pas forcément les porter tous de la même
manière on va donc venir développer un
algorithme qui permettra d'optimiser la
qualité sonore et ça de façon
individualisée personne par personne ça
veut donc dire que quelle que soit la
forme de votre oreille quelle que soit
la façon dont vous allez venir les
porter et bien le son sera toujours
optimal en fait pas non plus n'importe
quoi on les mett en traviole l'idée ici
c'est que vous ayez toujours quoi qui se
passe la meilleure expérience audio avec
un son 24 bits 96 kHz et un taux de
transmission de 990 kbit par seconde
parlons aussi de l' tui puisque l' tui
est 32 % plus résistant que la
génération précédente et la charnière a
été travaillée pour plus de 100000
ouvertures et fermetures donc là on peut
y aller faire un petit moment Huawei
s'est dit ok on va le vérifier comme ça
il y aura pas de mauvais surprise pour
les consommateurs plus de 100000 fois je
vais pas le faire 100000 fois comme ça
mais en tout cas ici il vous
garantissent plus de 100000 et fermeture
donc vous êtes vraiment peinard et à
noter ici en plus que votre ettu est 4,5
% plus petit par rapport à la génération
précédente autre point sur lequel Huawei
ne fait pas les choses à moitié c'est
sur les codec vous allez avoir ici deux
bons codec pour avoir une meilleure
qualité audio le l2hc 2.0 et le leldac
pour profiter de la meilleure expérience
audio il faut venir ici dans qualité du
son et vous switchez sur priorité à la
qualité du son ensuite vous allez dans
Paramètres dans codec audio Bluetooth et
vous venez choisir quel que deck vous
voulez mettre et on a ici des écouteurs
qui sont certifiés Hwa a wireless audio
mais également IR audio wireless vous
allez retrouver ici votre niveau de
batterie au niveau de vos écouteurs et
au niveau de votre étuille voyz un truc
qui m'a vraiment plu et que je viens
vraiment chercher lorsque j'écoute ici
des écouteurs comme ça et bien c'est de
retrouver voyez notamment sur des
guitares c'est tous ces sortes de
texture moi je suis gratteux j'aime
retrouver de la texture dans les sons
guitar et ici je les ai mais également
les timbres de voix j'aime bien les voix
un peu plus rocailleuses et ici je
trouve vraiment ce qui me plaît en terme
de timbre et en terme de texture et puis
il y a un truc qui est quand même super
bien ici qui est vraiment bien fait sont
les effets sonores vous avez donc six
écoaliseur notamment le mode par défaut
l'amplification des basses
l'amplification des aigues la voix
Symphony et IFI life moi ce que je
trouve vraiment intéressant c'est qu'il
y a vraiment une douceur ici des fois
che certains concurrents on va venir
retrouver des équaliseurs qui vont être
un petit peu plus fouillis qui vont
venir vraiment y aller de façon un peu
bourine lorsque vous venez augmenter les
aiguses vous sentez vraiment que les
aiguses montent d'un coup et c'est pas
ouf ici ça reste très fin très Cali et
ça une fois de plus c'est super
intéressant vous pouvez venir ensuite
faire plus en ajouter et vous avez en
tout 10 bandes de fréquence on parle de
60 Hz jusqu'à 16 kg vous choisissez donc
comme vous voulez en fonction de votre
oreille en fonction de ce que vous aimez
écouter et vous allez le retrouver
ensuite ici en bas autre sujet
extrêmement intéressant c'est la
réduction active de bruit parce que bien
évidemment Huawei n'aurait pas travaillé
c'est freebuds Pro 3 sans venir
optimiser ici la réduction active de
bruit ils vont encore plus loin par
rapport à ce qu'on avait avant on a
aujourd'hui l'ANC active noise
cancelling pour la réduction active de
bruit c'est la version 3.0 qui va venir
optimiser votre ANC en temps réel avec
une réduction active de bruit qui est
amélioré de 50 % c'est pareil 50 % par
rapport à la génération précédente donc
si vous êtes par exemple dans un
environnement bruyant on se parle du
métro on va se parler dans un avion on
va se parler dans un train dans la rue
également s'il y a énormément de bruit
autour de vous et pourquoi pas dans un
restaurant ou un bar un peu bruillant et
bien ici vous allez avoir une expérience
totalement optimisée grâce à la
réduction de bruit actif qu'on va
retrouver ici a la NC 3.0 pour la
réduction du bruit vous allez ici dans
son vous allez avoir trois modes
différents soit réduction du bruit soit
aucun soit perception et vous pouvez
également mettre le mode voie le mode
perception est super intéressant comme
ça il va venir s'adapter à l'environ et
il y a également un autre point sur
lequel Huawei est venu travailler
optimiser grâce à de l'intelligence
artificielle la réduction active de
bruit puisque le son extérieur ne va pas
être le même d'un environnement à
l'autre et bien ici vous avez un algo
intelligent qui va venir optimiser le
niveau de réduction de bruit actif qui
va venir injecter dans vos oreilles et
ça en temps réel c'est ici l' adaptative
noise cancellation vous avez ensuite le
H protect au niveau des écouteurs qui
vous permettra de venir les retrouver
très très facilement lorsque vous les
avez perdu même les localiser après sur
la carte il y a un autre sujet qui est
super intéressant c'est vos appels
téléphoniques puisqu'on utilise bien
évidemment ses écouteurs pour écouter de
la musique c'est normal moi des fois je
les utilise même sans son juste pour me
couper un peu du bruit extérieur et je
le fais notamment dans les transports en
commun lorsque je veux un peu de calme
juste de l'inquiétude mais je les
utilise également pour venir passer des
appels téléphoniques et une fois de plus
Huawei est venu optimiser l'expérience
pour vos appels téléphoniques il y a ici
surtout une toute nouvelle architecture
qui permet de mieux capter le son de
votre voix avec notamment un micro à
conduction osseuse qui va être couplé en
plus avec trois autres micros pour venir
mieux capter le son lors des appels
téléphoniques avec en plus une une
annulation du bruit en arrière-plan qui
est amélioré de 5 dB et vous avez le VPU
qui est 2,5 fois supérieur à la
génération précédente ici il y a
vraiment cette technologie qui est mis
en avant c'est la pure Voice 2.0 il y a
vraiment une clarté de voix qui va être
totalement optimisée grâce à un
algorithme de réseau neuronal profond le
DNN multicanal on se fait une démo lors
d'un appel téléphonique je suis en train
de passer un coup de fil directement
avec mon P60 pro je vais mettre une
musique d'ambiance d'aéroport derrière
et on va voir ça va être annulé de
l'autre côté pour la personne qui est à
l'autre bout du fil donc là voyez je met
le bruit
il y a quand même vachement de bruit si
vous écoutez l'ambiance travers le micro
mais lors de l'appel téléphonique qui
est en train d'être fait directement
avec ce smartphone et bien ça vient
annuler en fait tout le bruit ça vient
réduire énormément le bruit l des appels
téléphoniques et c'est tout l'intérêt
ici qu'on va retrouver je suis en train
de parler directement de passer un coup
de fil et pour autant il y a vraiment le
bruit de l'aéroport derrière ça permet
de distinguer ça permet de détacher la
voix et ça c'est quand même super bien
et en plus de ça un algorithme pour
venir annuler encore plus le bruit du
vent lorsque vous êtes à l'extérieur oui
parce que si il y a du vent chez vous
fermez les fenêtres ça suffira largement
ça va venir annuler le vent qui va
jusqu'à 9 m par seconde ça va on évite
les tempes en tout cas et surtout
améliorer ici de 80 % et Huawei bien
évidemment ne s'arrête pas là est venu
travailler également sur la connectivité
puisque vous pouvez venir connecter vos
freebuds Pro 3 à deux appareils en même
temps qu'on peut venir utiliser
indépendamment bien évidemment sur un
Android notamment ici un P60 pro mais
également sur iOS le up de connction ça
c'est quand même pas mal aussi le de
connexion puisque vous pouvez venir
autoriser la connexion multiple entre
différents appareils ce qui est aussi
super Simp c'est les commandes tactiles
regardez par exemple juste là là devant
là je viens appuyer une fois hop lecture
je réappuie une fois pause lorsque je
décrocher un appel téléphonique j'appuie
une fois l que je vais raccrocher
j'appuie une fois si maintenant jeis
venir switcher entre mes différents
modes de réduction de bruit active et
bien je fais un appui long sur les deux
écouteurs ici c'est le contrôle du bruit
vous choisissez ensuite ce que vous
voulez mettre réduction de bruit aucun
perception et après si on veut pas
mettre ça on peut mettre l'assistant
vocal ou alors carrément ne rien mettre
du tout lorsque je vais venir monter ou
baisser le son et bien là regardez hop
là je viens je pousse vers le haut comme
ça là lorsque je vais venir diminuer le
son je viens là et je glisse comme ça
tout simplement donc c'est extrêmement
simple l'autonomie globale c'est-à-dire
écouteur plus recharge sur les tuis vous
montez à 31 he avec la réduction de
bruit actif coupé si maintenant vous
laissez la réduction de bruit actif vous
montez jusqu'à 22h globale et par
écouteur et bien vous avez jusqu'à 6,5
he en écoute sans réduction de bruitille
active et jusqu'à 4,5 he avec la
réduction de bruitille active tout en
sachant ici en plus vous pouvez venir
recharger votre boîtier en fil aire mais
également s'en fil très facilement et
qu'il vous faudra 40 minutes pour avoir
une charge complète à qui s'adresse
Huawei si avec ses freebuds pro 3 et
bien il s'adresse à tous les melowan
tous ceux qui veulent écouter de la
musique de qualité avec une superbe
qualité sonore que ce soit avec de la
réduction active de bruit sans réduction
active de bruit avec un mode adaptatif
toutes celles et tous ceux qui veulent
profiter de la meilleure qualité audio
et bien ici peuvent aller sans aucun
problème sur les freebuds pro 3 et bien
évidemment également aux utilisateurs de
Smartphone de Huawei à noter également
que vos buds et uniquement vos buds
c'est-à-dire vos buds mais pas votre
étui sont IP54 donc s'il pleut tout se
passera bien plusué transpiration pour
le sport et qui a un appérage de
proximité c'est c'est très simple
lorsque vous venez les appérer pour la
première fois et bien vous faites un
petit appui long ici là sur le bouton
juste sur le côté vous ouvrez et il se
connecte très facilement à votre
Smartphone vous avez également le test
de porort deembout de l'oreille pour
être sûr qu'il correspondent réellement
à votre oreille les mises à jour qu'il
faut venir faire et puis ensuite vos
différents paramètres la détection de
por la latence dynamique si vous êtes
méloman si vous êtes passionné de
musique si vous voulez une superbe
expérience que soit pour vos appels
téléphoniqu pour écouter de la musique
quels que soient les endroits sans être
embêté par le vent sans être êté par le
bruit sans être embêté par la foule et
bien ici vous pouvez aller très très
facilement et les yeux fermés bien
évidemment sur les Huawei freebuds Pro 3
je vous le dis une fois de plus vous
avez une réduction de 20 € avec le code
à Monsieur Greux tous les détails sont
juste en bas dans la description au lieu
de 199,99 € vous toucher à
179,99 € et ça c'est quand même
vachement bien et puis vous l'avez vu il
y a de l'intelligence artificielle ici
directement dans ses écouteurs et
puisqu'on parle d'intelligence
artificielle je vous invite à venir voir
ma vidéo avec 9 Ia qui vont radicalement
changer votre vie et ça aussi c'est un
sujet super
intéressant